look at this oh my god wow you know now
I'm thinking back to the first time I
saw him I had Sullivan and the whole
thing how you doing Paul good to see you
I'm good thanks yeah you look well yeah
I'm feeling good all right man I gotta
just soak this in that I'm sitting here
with you that's pretty amazing you've
got to soak it in what about me I have a
million questions you were the guy who
said to Michael Jackson you should get
into publishing isn't that great yeah do
you love the irony and he bought all
your songs yeah and you've said to him
listen I'll give you a fair market value
let me buy my songs I want to own them
and he won't do it you know it was a
funny thing we had a quite a good little
relationship he rang me up on Christmas
Day I think he was and I heard this
hello he's very weird yeah I said hello
I thought uh oh wait a minute this
American fans got my uh home phone
number right this is weird hello yes
he's not here yeah so I promise her
anyway he came over I said what do you
want to do he should make some hits I
said well that sounds good so we we got
a little relationship there it was quite
good fun and it is true he did ask me he
said you know got some advice Paul I
told him took him aside and said and
think about getting into music
publishing and I thought he was joking
he said I'm gonna get yours well I won't
show you on the back good one you know I
thought that was a joke and then I just
got wrong up he said he's got yours and
I thought hey you know what is weird I
don't mind that because he you know had
all the cash someone was selling it and
he bought it what I don't like is that
I've actually written to him a couple of
times who Edition
saying Michael don't you think after
like even if I was just a writer on the
payroll after 30 years right of being
reasonably successful for this company
you now own don't you think I could have
a raise yeah and you know he said oh
well that's just business I said yeah
yeah and we've never talked about it he
won't even answer my letters oh so you
know what if we haven't got that great a
relationship I did read recently that
because of some uh cash flow problems
he's having aren't your songs up for
grabs in fact this might be a good time
for me and you to go in and buy these
songs yeah you know so no I think it may
be true I don't know you know you never
know what's room and what isn't I don't
have access to his accounts but um uh
you know that may be true I know you do
I have access to everyone's accounts we
could go and buy them you know the
trouble is I wrote them for nothing
right and buying them back at these
phenomenal sums it's just it rubs you
the wrong way
foreign